hi I'm Naz malicious a developer
advocate on the Android team and welcome
to this episode of dead bytes in today's
episode we're gonna cover the new app
indexing feature that we recently
announced for Google search for Android
currently when you do a Google search on
the web you get results that are links
to websites it's not easy to get your
Android apps by doing web searches I
mean you can find results that link to
listings on the Play Store but you can't
do much more than that with app indexing
you will now be able to point Google
search users on Android directly to
content within your app Google search
will be able to surface deep links
within your app directly in search
results and provide a call to action
button to launch your app directly this
is particularly useful when the search
terms are really specific and can be
resolved to content that's presented
inside of your Android application for
example imagine that you run a
restaurant review website and have an
app that also shows restaurant reviews
thanks to the app indexing feature when
a Google search is done in a mobile
device for a restaurant and one of your
reviews is a search result they will now
be able but the user will now be able to
open that result directly in your
application if they have it installed
you also have control over when Google
displays the open in app call to action
button so that you can decide when you
want to guide people to content on your
website and when you want to highlight
your Android app now in order to enable
app linking you have to perform at least
two things one on your website and one
in your Android application on your
website you have to annotate each page
with app links that can be opened in
your mobile application you'll need to
specify how the pages content can be
mobile it can be opened in your Android
app now in the Android app you have to
add intent filters for deep linking in
your application manifest to specify how
to reach specific content inside of the
application correctly configuring both
your website and app allows Google to
crawl and process both the website and
app and index the relationship between
the web page and your app correctly this
helps our algorithms show the open in
app button
in the search results if appropriate now
each page on your site can specify how
its contents can be loaded in your app
we offer two equivalent ways to tell
Google's algorithms about the
relationships between the page and your
application and these are using link
elements in the head section of the
pages HTML or you can use link elements
in the site map URL element specifying
the page and again for more details
please read the blog posts that will be
released in order for Google to index
the content in your application and for
users to enter your application from
Google search results you must specify
intent filters in your application
manifest that define how to reach
specific content inside of your
application and again for more details
on doing this please reference the blog
posts now if you're an Android developer
who has a web presence and you want more
control over how your content is
accessed from search via your website or
your Android application app indexing is
a great feature for you to explore also
enabling your website an application for
indexing is a great way to increase
engagement by making your content more
discoverable and more accessible to
users directly from the search results
page for more information on app
indexing please visit the link on the
screen and read the Google developers
blog post and the webmaster blog post as
well thanks for joining us today and
take care